if it's on camera we're not doing an
interview why we'll explain why how do
you feel about that influence that you
have you better be careful we're coming
for your children there buddy about
Maring Nation yes I'm going to do you're
going to resign I'm going I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on P sens Israel's bombing
intensifies in Gaza as a nation marks
one month since the Hamas Terror attacks
is the Middle East at risk of allout War
I'll talk live and exclusively to the
Exile Crown Prince of
Iran anti-semitic attacks and sword
since the War Began but with calls to
ban Pro Palestinian marches are we
putting fundamental rights at risk over
so-called hate speech or
debate and shaie Luke was the dancing
tattoo artist who became a tragic symbol
of her Mass's brutality on October the
7th with her death now confirmed tonight
her father has a powerful warning for
the
[Music]
West live from the news building in
London this is pi Morgan uncensored good
evening from London welcome to Pi Morgan
un censored today marks 1 month since
Hamas terrorists in invaded Israel and
butchered more than 1400 people now
October the 7th is destined to become a
date we never forget like 911 its morbid
memories will echo through history but
as Israelis today look back in anger and
in grief the rest of the world's
beginning to contemplate what else that
date will come to represent would it
plunge the Middle East into a deadly
wider crisis will the simmering racial
resentment caused bitterness and
bloodshed across the world will it nail
the coffin of a two-state solution prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu has given
his first answer to the big question of
what happens to Gaza when the war is
over and frankly it's a major cause of
concern Israel will
for an indefinite period will have the
overall uh security
responsibility this means Netanyahu
plans to effectively occupy Gaza
completely for an indefinite period long
after the bombing and bloodshed is done
that to me is a massive error of
judgment Hamas says more than 10,000
Palestinians are already dead since
October the 7th there 10,000 grieving
families who will blame Israel and
Netanyahu for destroying their lives and
as a bombing intensifies their Fury and
Malice will surely spread there will be
no safe or Fair Way for the Palestinian
people to live under an Israeli heel no
path to peace net Netanyahu must surely
know this last night I asked Israeli
president Isaac Herzog if Netanyahu
himself is now a barrier to peace he
gave a diplomatic answer that was I
would say far from a ringing
endorsement the day after the war will
come where all these issues will be
discussed we are a vibrant democracy we
don't shy away from anything but right
now we're all United we're all United in
one goal we must return the hostages
back we must overcome and Prevail
against our enemies and we must bring
peace and security
to our borders and our peoples this is
my only aim at this point and I get it
Israel's focused on wiping out Hamas
after what they did to their people on
October the 7th but what happens next
will change the course of history
Palestinians need new leaders who accept
a Jewish State Israel needs a new leader
who recognizes that Palestinians too
deserve a state and the same human
rights as Israelis Netanyahu has
honestly divided to rule he propped up
Hamas to split the pal Palestinians with
now catastrophic consequences now he's
making aury calls for more lengthy
occupation when tensions couldn't be
higher I don't know frankly who should
control Gaza when Hamas or if Hamas is
wiped out but I do know it can't be
Benjamin
Netanyahu well my first guest tonight
was a guest of promis Netanyahu in
Israel early this year when he was fed
as the most prominent Iranian to visit
Israel in history the exiled Crown
Prince of Iran Reser pvy joins me now
from Washington DC uh great to see you
uh Crown Prince I really appreciate you
joining the program I've interviewed you
several times over the years in
different circumstances so it's great to
have you on uncensor for the first time
first of all your reaction good I'm
sorry sorry good to talk to you again
Pierce after about 12 years I think last
time we spoke so it is when I was it is
it's good to see you um let me ask you
first of all your reaction we're a month
in now to the Israel Hamas War what is
your reaction to What has been going
on Pierce I think that the world cannot
ignore the elephant in the room and that
is since the rise of uh radical Islam as
a result of the Iranian Revolution that
took my country Hostage to begin with
and has since forment this kind of uh
antagonism Regional instability
warmongering uh supporting terrorist
groups and what have you we should not
really be surprised that at the tail end
we are faced with this kind of uh R
rises in tension and I think it's uh
it's telling that you know we have to
cure the disease ultimately and until
and we don't put an end at the ideology
itself I don't think we can really be
hopeful to have a legitimate peace in
the region for the best interest of the
people living there and of course beyond
our region how it impacts the rest of
the world yesterday I interviewed the
president of Israel Isaac Herzog I know
you met him as well as prime minister
Netanyahu on your historic visit to
Israel and he said this about
Iran there's an Empire of evil from tan
emanating with a whole culture of hate
to eradicate all of
us would you agree with that
look I think uh president Herzog uh
prime minister Netanyahu and I think
along with that many leaders and Beyond
leaders people in the world who by now
have hosted in their respective
countries in the west and elsewhere
Iranians who were forced to flee the
country as a result of this regime to
understand that what the Iranian people
are like and want is totally different
that that the regime in Iran and I've
always asked for uh uh the world
Community including media when they talk
about Iran to specify that they are
talking about the regime in Iran not the
people of Iran so when we say Iran I
want to make clear that this is not the
Iranian people you're talking about but
the regime that's very important as a
distinction because I think that while
the problem correctly emanates from tan
and I've been saying this all these
years that the eye of the octopus is in
fact in tan and we are busy fighting the
tentacle
without putting out the Beast itself of
course in that statement I think he's
correct the question however is how can
this change come about and there's a lot
to discuss about this matter well there
is and of course Central to this right
now is the war against Hamas a terror
group who've been in charge of Gaza for
17 years or so um really ran a
repressive regime of their own against
their own their own people continued to
treat Palestinian civilians as just some
some kind of military Capital that can
be expended on a whim it seems um and
everyone who saw what happened on
October the 7th who has an ounce of
humanity will completely understand why
Israel is going so hard now for Hamas
but the problem for The Wider world and
certainly for The Wider Arab Community
is that in trying to eradicate Hamas who
who live among civilians there are
thousands and thousands of completely
innocent often children half of the
casualties are reported to be children
being killed in the process uh is there
a moral equivalence here is there a line
that Israel shouldn't Cross or is this
idea that they should be proportionate
just for the birds if you're in a war
and you're trying to wipe out a terror
group well again the the principle
funding and the principal support that
comes to these groups must have a money
Trail and a Source in terms of uh what's
keeping them uh going uh it's not a
secret that the regime in tan has been
behind most of these groups has financed
them has armed them has used them at
proxies to advance their agenda in the
region with the ultimate goal of
exporting an ideology and force the
world into assimilation under a modern
de caliphate this is not simply in the
region Pierce mind you today we hear
this ominous sound of a radical
islamists who are trying to shape a
different future for countries even in
Europe hoping to gain a majority and
force uh uh the laws to change uh in the
way they want to see the the the world
govern under this kind of uh caliphate
this is really a challenge that faces
all of us it's not just an issue to
Israel having to deal with the problem
of having been attacked by a terrorist
group it is the nature of the Beast
itself as I said it's a disease that
needs to be cured and while you can deal
with the symptoms if the Cure is not
found and in my opinion The Cure is to
put an end to what is the source behind
this extremism this radicalism the
problem will never U dissipate one has
to do what they have to do sometimes
wrong sometimes it's a moral issue as
you pointed but that doesn't solve the
ultimate problem I believe that the
sooner we solve the root cause of the
problem all all of these issues will
ultimately find a way to find a proper
resolution with every uh interest of uh
humanitarian and Liberties of all people
Israelis Palestinians Arabs Iranians and
the whole world we have to work together
with the problem and not you know uh uh
Kick the Can down the road and and hope
that by Miracle the problem is going to
dissipate it's not going to do you have
any doubt that Iran was behind what
happened on October the 7th in terms of
the scale of it in terms of the quantity
of of you know Firepower that they took
over the Border I mean does it look to
you like an Iran sponsored
operation well I think that uh hours
after the attack there were already some
Palestinian Banner that were hanging on
some public buildings in tan and a short
visit
thereafter of uh Iran's officials
with the Hamas Representatives this
simply is not a coincidence it must have
been in some form or shape planned or
anticipated and in fact they haven't
denied the fact Hamas itself has had
thanked officially one of their uh
representative I saw a clip somewhere
where he actually acknowledges the
support coming from tan so uh they're
not denying it and uh and I think that's
a fact that is hardly contested by
anyone who understand enough about the
Quagmire uh in the Middle East and and
Iran having been The Godfather of
terrorism all these years final question
we've seen Isis pretty well wiped out
we've seen Al-Qaeda severely diminished
in its ability to operate if Israel was
to be successful in eradicating Hamas uh
and affected regime change in Gaza could
you see this spilling over potentially
to regime change in Iran and if it did
would you be Keen to go back there and
assume the power that was removed from
you in
1979 well pierce my formula for changing
Iran is of course based on popular
sovereignty and the Free Will of the
Iranian people that can only choose
their future once liberated from this
regime that denies them the right to
freely Choose Or elect whoever they want
in the future my process for change in
Iran is to make sure that we have a
democratic transition post regime
collapse that we can have a constituent
assembly When people's Representatives
will debate what will be the best course
for the country in the future to offer
the Iranian people by referendum a
chance to ratify the proposed
Constitution hopefully based on the
universal Declaration of Human Rights
which are clear you know separation of
church from State and it is for the
Iranian people to ultimately V their
choice I'm not running for any office or
have any any other uh ambition in mind
other than to serve that process and be
a facilitator for that process and speak
on behalf of all Iranians for their
right to choose and freely determine
their their future I do however believe
that the solution in Iran is regime
change and this regime will never change
its Behavior which is why in 40 Years of
trying the the the the biggest problem
and flaw in Western policy foreign
policy Vis of Iran was an expectation of
behavior change this regime's DNA
doesn't go along with the values that
Iranians cherish that is also cherished
in free countries human rights equality
putting an end to any form of
discrimination so at the end of the day
we need to make sure that people in the
world if they truly want to help the
process of stability and and democracy
and freedom to be on the side of the
Iranian people and forget about
continuing to negotiate with a regime
that has never had any intentions to
reform itself the time has come for
change at the ask of the Iranian people
and then therefore I think the world has
a golden opportunity to use the best
allies they have in the process as the
instrument of change the Iranian people
themselves but they cannot fight alone
we need to have support from the
Coalition of the Willing in free
societies and people who do uh Champion
democracy and human rights but one word
answer if you got the opportunity
democratically would you go back and
Lead
Iran I will help uh my fellow
competitors as much as I I can with no
personal ambition I I don't think that
uh uh the issue for me is anything
beyond helping the creation of the kind
of Institutions well well beyond the
constitutional government because Civil
Society is the ultimate Watchdog for
society and we need to strengthen this
institution to make democracy a lasting
system in a country okay I'll take that
as a yes not 76 words
res no I I will I will help any way that
I can of course if the opportunity
presented
it's good to talk to you again thank you
very much indeed for joining me Resa
palvi thank you very much thank you
pierce the exiled Crown Prince of Iran
fascinating stuff on sensor next reports
of anti-Semitism and islamophobia have
saw since the War Began but are these
claims being used to stifle legitimate
criticism of both Israel and Hamas we'll
debate with an very eminent
[Music]
panel
[Applause]
[Music]
well welcome back reports of
anti-Semitism Assa in both the UK and
the US and indeed around the world since
the Israel Hamas War Began many pro
Palestine supporters however believe the
criticism of Israel is being censored by
the claims of hate speech last night
Israeli president Isaac hog told me that
a pro Palestine March planned on the
UK's Armistice Day should be banned so
our claims of anti-Semitism and
islamophobia being used to stifle
legitimate criticism and indeed Free
Speech or rather tensions on our streets
in real danger of boiling over well here
to debate all this is the founder of the
end Jew hatred movement Brooke Goldstein
the host of system update Glenn
Greenwald and the author of go back to
where you come from commentator wajahat
wajahat Ali welcome to all of you uh let
me start with you Brooke I want to read
you what you tweeted me recently because
I think this will set the tone for this
debate you said peers I've been on the
show I know you to be a fair journalist
but I don't understand why you're giving
these Islam nais such a large platform
over and over again to spread their
venom there comes a point when you have
heard their message and you've done your
duty would you likewise host every
single member of the SS in Nazi Germany
for the sake of debunking I hate to say
you're not doing a good job at it their
lies of propaganda are so carefully
crafted that the more you put herass
apologies on the more effective they
become asking people to debate them to
debate how many babies were killed
whether it's by beheading or by stabbing
or by burning babies alive is tasteless
and disgraces the memory of the innocent
Jewish people who've been killed at what
point does your journalism become a
propaganda tool for terrorism they send
their best and brightest to you to
engage in mental masturbation acrobatics
and they're running circles around you
with all due respect enough in the
battle between good and evil there is no
journalistic obligation to continue to
put evil on a plat platform to be
debated so I mean that seems to me a
pretty strong way to start this debate
because what you seem to be saying is
that so long as I have pro-israeli
voices that's fine as long as I have a
lot of people like you who just have one
view of this then I'm a fair journalist
but the moment I Stray into people who
are pro
Palestinian in a very passionate manner
then somehow I'm uh failing in my
journalistic duty and I would say that
that right there's part of the problem
Brook because I have tried to turn this
show into a genuinely Fair platform for
all sides all arguments all voices and I
think we've been getting the audiences
that that reflects which is people like
it they like to hear both sides why
don't
you so Pierce thank you for bringing up
that tweet um first I want to say that's
not what I'm saying at all there's Pro
Palestinian there's pro-israel but
you've been having pro-hamas people on
your platform and you're giving them an
opportunity to spew their virulent
anti-Semitism and their propaganda that
justifies Hamas terrorism it's one thing
to debate issues of geopolitics and
National can you name one right right in
front of me I can't I was replying to
something that uh name one you had
someone on that I was name one guest
I've had in a month you know I don't
have name now but can name someone H
with all due respect BR with all respect
you tweeted this lengthy attack on me
and my
journalistic talk I'm simply asking you
the people you have on right now hang on
Brooke hang on if you're going to do
that I don't think it's unreasonable to
say who which of my Pro Palestinian
guests expressed support for Hamas
because I must have missed that was
jahat Ali who is on the show right now
with us for example has de deep
connections to the Muslim Brotherhood
the Muslim Brotherhood is the mother of
all terrorist organizations it spawned
Hamas a designated terrorist group which
is currently killing both gazan and
Israeli civilians was shahat Ali who is
on the platform with me right now and
your audience needs to know this sat on
the board of the Muslim Student
Association which is widely known to be
a Muslim Brotherhood entity he also has
writings that are crossposted on the
English Lang anguage website of the
Muslim Brotherhood he has crossposted
authors who call for the eradication of
the Jewish State he's a leading writer
at cap the center for American progress
which also has ties to the Muslim
Brotherhood he has criticized cracking
down on the Muslim Brotherhood in Egypt
and of course he just published an
article saying that he's against Hamas
because it's politically exp to him she
is connected to the musim brother that's
who you have on your show before I go to
him you just said he just he just
written a piece condemning Hamad so you
kind of kill your own argument let me go
uh to J well he's sucking and blowing at
the let me go to the man you the that
they are using right now let me go to
the man you've been accusing what do you
say to
that well first of all excellent
pronunciation of my name Brooke thank
you also it's pretty amazing that for a
human rights lawyer you really don't
seem to care much about human beings who
happen to be Palestinians or Muslim or
Arab it's like a who actually an AR risk
my life to make a movie about Arab
children I risk my life to make a movie
about Arab children and was given an
award by the United Nations for my
advocacy work for Palestinian children
good job on doing your research let him
answer you
please you are the hero and you are the
victim but let me say the following uh
let me say that well the person who
accused me of being the Muslim
Brotherhood and the person who's accused
us anyone who's Pro Palestinian of being
a Nazi which is by the way what Brian
Mass said Republican he said there's no
such thing as Palestinian civilians
because they're just like Nazis right
but anyway let me say this cuz peers
I've seen your show I appr you let speak
you condemn the Muslim Brotherhood let
me say this I'm going to go a step
forward look at this this is what I'm
going to do because I've seen people
with my melanin on pier show I've
proactively been asked to condemn Hamas
I condemn Hamas I condemn Hezbollah I
condemn Islamic Jihad I condemn Muslim
Brotherhood I condemn chocolate hummus I
condemn uh I condemn anti-Semitism I
condemn islamophobia I condemn white
supremacy I also condemn Israel's
occupation I condemn settler violence
against Palestinians that have killed
over 100 people in the West Bank I
condemn Netanyahu using dehumanizing
language that you use such as calling
every Palestinian amalik I condemn the
Heritage Minister saying that he wants
to drop a nuke a nuk on Gaza I have
condemned all of that do you Brooke join
me in condemning everything that I have
condemned because I think as a human
rights lawyer anyone who cares about
Humanity they should condemn everything
that I have condemned Brooke 100% so why
if you condemn the Muslim Brotherhood
are you publishing with the center for
American progress which is strong ties
to the Muslim Brotherhood and why do you
allow your papers to be crossposted on
Muslim Brotherhood websites why have you
denied Jewish indig genuity to Judea why
you know BR I'm going to get I'm going
to jump States for cre I'm going jum
you come and you say these things on
television but you write the exact
opposite your writing I'm going to jump
in and come to Glenn he's been waiting
very patiently as as you guys have been
going at it Glen in a way this kind of
is reflective of of the debate I I
thought we should be having because it
seems to me that uh a lot of people are
simply not prepared to tolerate other
views generally in society we've got to
a place where people get cancelled if
they don't toal don't have the opinion
that a certain group of people have
decided is the only opinion that's
allowed how have we got there how has it
been through this War I mean to me
watching Twitter X as it now is in this
war is like this terrible assault on the
brain um it's it's just people screaming
in a self-righteous often fake news
oriented way uh trying to scream their
opponents into submission where has
honest democratic debate gone what are
we doing about
this yeah I think you're right that uh
Brooke your first guest is a perfect
reflection of what has gone so wrong
with this discourse ever since October
7th she did two things that has been
really pathological in terms of how
we're trying to conduct discourse about
a very serious issue number one she
equates every person who criticizes
Israel or who defends the Palestinian
cause of being an Islam and Nazi or
somehow being associated with terrorists
as she did with waj with I have a lot of
differences but he has never done
anything like that the idea that the CER
for American progress can I you doing
exactly
must you had a chance to speak I want to
hear from
Glenn the idea that the center for
American progress is some sort of crypto
terrorist group but in fact it is the
most mainstream Democratic party
platform that hosted Benjamin yet nahu
that completely supports Israel just
like the Democratic party does is
derangement and this attempt to accuse
everyone of being a bigot or an
anti-semite the minute they express any
criticism of Israel I think is very
toxic but the worst thing appears is
that ever since a month ago when this
started we have had a Spate of
censorship throughout the West aimed
only at one side which is the pro
Palestinian side France banned All Pro
Palestinian protests you can have
pro-israel protests you can go and say
you think Gaza should be flattened that
all gazin should be eradicated like many
people say what you can't do though is
March in opposition to the French policy
the British Home Secretary said waving a
Palestinian flag may be a crime in the
US they're banning Pro Palestinian
groups so we can have our differences
obviously this is a very inflammatory
issue but what we should not do is try
and suppress healthy debate through
State censorship through Banning one
side from expressing themselves or
accusing everybody of being a terrorist
and a Nazi because they express
criticism for the Israeli government
something which many Jews like s and
many Israelis do as well okay let me go
to Brooke I want to ask Brook I I want
to ask you a question I'm actually is
this Pro Palestinian the murder and
bludgeoning of a Jewish man at a pramas
rally these are not pro Palestinian
rallies what is banned is pro Hamas in
Europe Hamas is a designated terrorist
group and you should understand the
difference between that when you lock
students in a library at Cooper's Union
and bang on the door and threaten them
with violence that is not free speech
when you beat up Jews because you are
projecting your hatred of a foreign
government on somebody because of what
they look like or what their religion is
that is bigotry that is not free speech
and your other
two speak I to bring I want bring in
please to respond to that you can't just
keep talking you made you made a point
let me go to a jaw hat for
response this is the big difference
between you and me Brooke and there are
many differences that I have the
capacity to empathize with the suffering
of the Jewish people and with
Palestinians that when I see
anti-Semitism when I see Jews were
afraid in Europe and in America I
condemn it when I see Muslims afraid of
islamophobia I condemn it when I see
wadia who was a six-year-old boy
murdered murdered simply because he was
palestinian-american I condemned when I
see this man this 69y old man and their
their research right out to see whether
or not it was a hate crime I will
condemn it the difference between me and
you is that when I see dead children
when I see 4,000 Palestinian kids who
are killed it horrifies me as a human
rights lawyer I'm amazed why this does
not horrify you when you see 4,000 kids
kill this is not shocking for you it's
collateral damage now the the ID
yesterday say it can I finish can I the
IDF yesterday said the IDF yesterday
said stop interrupting me please IDF
yesterday said that of the 10,000 people
killed only 60 were Hamas operatives so
that means that means that 10,000 people
were killed by Israel in the past month
4,000 children more kids killed in the
past month than in the past three years
of all war zones uh the conflict zones
combined I say it's inhumane and
indecent do you condemn the 4,000 kids
that have been killed and as of
yesterday the ID said only 60 people
were Hamas operatives
the pro-israel and the pro socalled
Hamas Palestinian movement is that we
mourn the death of all civilians where
the pro Palestinian Hamas protest after
October the 7th were out on the street
celebrating the death of dead Jewish
civilians that is the difference and the
other
difference fa
to I want to bring sor
you fail to understand the concept of it
remains my show at the moment inter BR
that's enough for now I want to bring
law is very clear you've had a chance to
respond international law is very clear
you had a chance to
respond other panelists Glen yes I want
to bring Glenn I'm sorry Glenn so I just
let me let me ask Glen Glenn you're
you're a yeah Glen you're a Jewish man
uh when you look at what is going on
here I I will be completely candid I
said this to other guests in the last uh
couple of weeks I found what happened
October the 7th to be of un an
unbelievable scale of
barbaric terrorism beyond anything I've
seen in my lifetime to be honest with
you the way it was done and I completely
understand Israel's not only right but
duty to defend itself but is there a
line here that Israel shouldn't cross in
its attempt to eradicate Hamas when you
see
10,000 palestin Ians killed within the
space of four weeks and we know it's
going to get much much higher and so
many are children is there a moral line
that Israel shouldn't Cross or is their
argument that they've got to get rid of
Hamas and in war you have collateral
damage and in this case it's the
civilians who are living around Hamas
and it's awful but that's what has to
happen every decent person found the
Hamas Massacre on October 7th
reprehensible and morally unjust
justifiable the question though is what
does that mean that everything that
Israel does in response becomes
justifiable and the answer is clearly
not just like everything the United
States did in response to 911 which was
also morally horrific and unjustifiable
killed 3,000 Americans everything that
the United States did in response wasn't
morally justifiable simply by virtue of
the fact that they claimed to be doing
it in the name of avenging 911 they
tortured people there were secret camps
in Guantanamo they invaded and destroyed
Iraq a country of 26 million people
giving rise to Isis the laws of war were
created after World War II ironically
when the world looked at what happened
in World War II the atrocities there and
said we know there are going to be Wars
but there have to be limits you cannot
collectively punish a population that is
a war crime because certain people in
that country have done bad things you
cannot just bomb people indiscriminately
without regard to civilian life and how
many tens of thousands or even a 100
thousand Palestinians does Israel have
the right to kill in the name of trying
to destroy Hamas of course there are
humanitarian limits and laws of war that
were created after World War II that the
nberg tribunal said apply to every
country in the Future No Matter How just
your cause and I thought that was the
lesson of 911 that just because a
country is enraged and acting with a
quest for violence doesn't mean that
everything they do in the name of
avenging that terrorist attack becomes
justifiable or morally defensible much
of what the United States did wasn't and
much of what Israel is doing isn't
either okay Glen powerful words
un we run out of time but I will I will
get you back on the program because
you've been a terrific guest tonight uh
I've enjoyed that debate last thing I
just want to say is that Jews have led
the protests Jews have actually led the
protest Jews calling for a and
app I've got to leave it there I'm sorry
thank you very much indeed to my panel
appreciate you all joining me Glenn
Brooke with hat thank you very much
indeed I'll s to next a powerful
interview with the father of shaie Luke
the 22-year-old who was kidnapped and
killed by Hamas on October the 7th he
has a chilling warning for the
West we're here good morning everybody
hope you're well thanks for joining us
you're watching the independent republic
of Mike gra right here on talk TV
welcome to Friday night with Nadine here
on prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
tour today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
the I'm so rich Frank
I'm going to take the side of boozed up
Brits against these pomp you mean you're
not going to support mayor Jose
L stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like they highly
paid Consultants don't really know what
they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
there a threat that you'd be worried
about so are you saying that you're
being overwhelmed that you're inundated
we are really working hard for you and
we're just asking patients to be patient
with us are we only going to be trusting
sources like meta and Google and
Facebook and X for you known as Twitter
where is our where is our unbiased news
going to come from Welcome to the talk
it's really great to be back my Little
Darlings kids think all they have to do
is stay at home befe silly take pictures
of everything just shut down Tik Tok
then
yeah problem solved there you go spits a
but's do him all right but but he's now
middle class here Tess I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to him I know
know you're probably going to wo me
up this is talk
[Music]
TV welcome back to PB on S A Story of
shaie Luke is one that will stand as a
permanent reminder of hass's monstrous
brutality October the 7th a tattoo
artist aged just 22 was having the time
of her life at a music festival when she
was kidnapped by terrorists and paraded
through the streets on the back of a
pickup truck initially sh's family
received information she might have
survived but last week they were told
she was dead by the Israeli military
yesterday I recorded an extraordinary
interview with Shan's
father Mr Luke uh thank you so much for
joining me uh and please accept uh at
the start of this interview my deepest
condolences to you and your family for
the appalling news that your daughter
was indeed killed uh how are you coping
as a family to this news it's it's not
easy for a father to lose his his his a
child you know as as a father to father
and this beautiful girl Shen that was
dancing and happy and and she she drove
to this party Friday evening just before
before uh in the afternoon and uh with
all our friends there were like 3,000
people there dancing together the whole
night H drinking and talking and hugging
and loving and these this these parties
are are like crazy because the amount of
energy with all the people around is is
huge and there were dancing all night
and everything was fine until the
morning in the morning uh
they saw the rockets and they heard the
booms in the sky and they start leaving
the party but the the psychopath
terrorist of the Hamas attacked them on
the way and they just killed them on
spot and uh for me as a father to see
like from one side all this happiness
and light and light and beauty and from
the other side you see sadness and death
I think my my my girl was the the symbol
because she looked so beautiful and so
pure and so nice on the on one side of
the on the main Pages all over Europe
you could see my daughter on the left
side beautiful and and shiny and her
name was Shani and and happy and on the
other side of the of the main paper you
could see the people of the Hamas when
they br in in a crazy sadistic brutal
way they threw her in the back of a
pickup when her legs were broken and she
had a a wound on her head and it was for
me as a father it was really a crazy
thing you know we came into this Israel
is a great place you all must know it's
a great great place and we are a peace
Seekers we we never want to fight with
anyone but uh you know they came into
our land and they raped the girls and
babies and and chop pieces of the head
and uh and really to all my uh my my
Christian friends in in Europe and in
England I would like to tell you that
okay it happened here in Israel but it
will happen again in the future time all
over Europe it's only a matter of time
you know that in the Holocaust 6 million
Jews went to into the concentration
camps and and they were they were people
that read books and study all days
really and after that what happened is
around 60 million people all between 60
to 100 million people all over Europe
died and U and I pray to God that it
will not happen in Europe because it
happened here in Israel and these are
sadistic people they are rapist and they
are crazy people and you know what they
did is Unforgettable Unforgettable and
and nobody will ever forgive them nobody
Mr it is very hard as a father to to to
to have such such thing in but from the
other end you know I'm I'm happy and why
I'm happy because at least I know that
she's dead I know that she was dancing
all night before and she had the best
time of of her life and few seconds
after she died and she's not suffering
because I I I don't want to think what
they are doing to these beautiful girls
that are there in in in Gaza it's it's
crazy and there are psychopaths and they
sadistic people and you could the whole
world saw it by their own cameras not
ours by their own cameras
so sometimes it's better to know that
your daughter is dead and she didn't
suffer even that it's crazy you know we
are we are at the moment it's a crazy
time than than to be there and you don't
know what they're doing and what they're
not doing to her and and it's for me
gave me peace and peace of mind AB it's
terrific I have a daughter myself I
can't imagine the from father to father
and to all the fathers in the world that
love their kids and babies and and
little little you know beautiful girls
and it is very very difficult and you
must know
Europe it's on the way to you and you
you just you close your eyes and you
think oh it's far away it's in Israel
it's in the Middle East no it's already
in all of Europe and it's only a matter
of time until we'll that we will come
and and you'll see it and you must do
some actions now before it's too late
because we really we we we really love
you I've been many times in England and
the people there are so nice and so and
and so beautiful and so happy and your
life is really is a dream but you must
take care that H because this dream can
be gone and it and it can be so fast
that you you'll not noticed and and
please please really do things to to so
your dream will will will stay and that
your country will stay beautiful and
that your country will will be with the
love with the people that love light and
happiness and not dark and and death Mr
Luke your daughter was a peace activist
she she refused military service um it
makes it all the more senseless that she
should be a victim of such brutality and
barbarism how would you like her to be
remembered
Shen first of all as you can see she's
just on the left of me uh she's she is a
beautiful girl so first of all her
beauty the way that she was dancing and
she was happy and the whole the whole
thing of this dancing Act is is is is to
to bring like peace in the world this
was the whole idea of this dancing in
the South to bring peace to the people
of the world to bring happiness and
dancing and hugging and loving this is a
Shen and uh okay so I think that like
the people of the world you must know
you must decide on which side you are
such a powerful interview and there's
more from that interview on the pi
Morgan uncensored YouTube channel which
will be immediately after this show as
uh a lot of people watching that channel
now and you'll want to see that
interview because that's a man in the
deepest grip of grief uh and speaking so
powerfully un sensor next a major
development after most exive VI it's for
the family of Captain Tom
Moore
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to unsensed I'm joined by
my Pat the political journalist a stino
and the Times columnist Matthew S well
welcome to both of you Matthew where's
your mind at with this Dreadful
situation well I think the key point was
made by the Crown Prince of Iran in a
brilliant interview earlier this evening
where he said that Iran is behind the
Hamas attack and I think the Iranian
regime these religious fundamentalists
felt that there was a growing Accord uh
between Israel and the sunny world the
Abraham Accords uh looming R Ron with
Saudi Arabia and they one of the rec
well the veh of the attack the fact that
they videoed it I felt that it was a a
piece of psychology to inflame an
overreaction and from Israel right and
here's the point I would make to people
who don't really want to you know say
anything that remotely sounds
pro-israeli and all this is Hamas knew
exactly what they were doing and if Iran
were pulling the strings so did they
when they launched a terror attack of
that magnitude they knew exactly how
Israel would respond and they knew
thousands of innocent Palestinians would
die in the attacks that were going to
come back how is that good leadership
for the people of of Gaza well earlier
today I noted that the BBC have now
changed their their language around this
so they now say that Israel is at war
with Hamas rather than Israel is at war
with Gaza I think that is a pretty good
representation of the conflict but what
do you mean by me not saying anything
pro-israeli do you think that about you
I'm not talking about you no no I'm just
saying that there's been a trend of
people on the pro Palestinian side that
they don't even really want to condemn
what happened October the 7th they very
quickly want to move to criticism of
Israel and their Revenge attacks but I
just I you know I'm the moral maze for
me is I agree that they should get rid
of Hamas Hamas are openly boasting about
attacking them again and again and again
only last week they said that right they
make no bones about what they want to do
so Israel has to defend itself and how
else do you do it frankly than going in
there and killing them that's not
something I can solve but I mean you
know you've got to think about the
people who are living in the gasa strip
who are living under the regime of Hamas
but how else do you get rid of Hamas
well look that's not for me to answer
but I it is says they don't agree with
it as an answer but I do think there is
there is a huge you know argument here
for Hamas being you know if they are
actually Sheltering in hospitals and
ambulances as the IDF claim then the
people who are also the gazan people who
are Palestinian people excuse me who are
in those hospitals they are under their
rule right they are so that's a point I
mean I think that's an interesting point
Matthew I mean there's no doubt I've
seen interviews with Palestinians who
are just fearful of saying anything
against Hamas because Hamas is a terror
group that terrorizes its own people
they terrorize innocent Palestinians you
know they use them as human Shields they
deliberately use mosques and hospitals
and schools as places for their
operations and they don't really care if
innocent Palestinians die this is true
but it's also worth taking a step back
to understand that Iran is part of a
rising autocratic axis along with China
Russia and North Korea Iran is sending
drones to Putin it is selling oil to
China China's buying discounted oil from
Putin financing his War Machine uh North
Korea is providing weapons to Putin
getting nuclear secrets in return one
has to take a step back and understand
the broader context in which this is
unfolding there is war in Europe and I
think that if China and it's not
impossible makes a move on Taiwan there
would be war in Europe there' be war in
the Middle East and in the indopacific
it is absolutely vital the Western
leaders understand the deeper Dynamics
around what's happening because one of
the things that is unquestionably a
consequence of Israel's overreaction is
it is polarizing West societies and our
ability to act in a unified way to
preserve Liberty which is under threat
about this whole debate for example
about the march on Saturday you know
there is a contradiction You could argue
that a lot of people who shout loudest
about Free Speech want to prohibit
Palestinian people Palestinian
supporters from marching on that day
which was a day which remembers the
Battle For Freedom including freedom of
speech MH well hearing everything that
Matthew just said there as well do you
not think that perhaps sella bravman
trying to curtail the potential marches
that are going on this weekend I mean it
almost feels quite pural when you have
people chanting Jihad and from The River
To The Sea and some of them holding
pramas banners they are actively
promoting a terrorist organization that
is no there is no argument that anyone
holding a prammer sign is breaking the
law and therefore should be arrested
there is no argument for that the
question is whether people who are
genuinely you who are quite upset or
outraged by the scale of the response of
the F would like to go in March and talk
about you know children that are dying
that is a fair humanitarian response for
the British people okay it's an
interesting debate um I want to move
just quickly to something else the
Captain Tom story I did an interview
with the with the family of Captain Tom
in which they made a number of
Revelations eventually that they
basically pocketed a lot of money nearly
a million pounds themselves from the
books and so on which people would have
assumed would have gone to the
foundation they've just been told today
by local planners that the whole
building they built
uh you know using really fraudulently I
would argue Captain Tom Foundation as
the background to do it they'd been
talking to raise it to the ground what's
your take on this I don't have strong
emotions mostly that I was disgusted by
this the British people I think showed
incredible generosity uh during that
period it was during Co wasn't it that
Captain Dom did did that walking and
when you have people who Leverage The
the moral Kudos of an individual of that
kind so widely expected and revered and
then trash it it basically undermines
people's sense that they want to give to
good caes and there's nothing the
British public hate more than feeling
like they've been done over and I'm
obsessed with the brass neck of all of
it I mean it's absolutely incredible
actually I think she actually might be
an icon when they finally confessed to
me after going off camera for half an
hour by the way to have a argument about
it that all that money 800,000 they come
from the books which had Captain Tom
saying this is my chance to raise more
money I mean it was all there black of
mine and all those little old ladies who
probably gave over their like you know
their last little bit of cash over to
her service you know they thought you
know what in all this we mustn't lose
track of the fact that he did an amazing
thing that guy was the very best of
Britain his family sadly I think you let
him down but thank you both for joining
me I appreciate it that's it from me
whatever you're up to Keep It Uncensored
good
[Music]
night
we're here good morning everybody hope
you're well thanks for joining us you're
watching the independent republic of
Mike gra right here on talk TV welcome
to Friday night with Nadine here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Pi's Morgan uncensored in
New York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job job what
have I done wrong and your face just
starred out at me me and you conquer
time who wins you do you know what I
love about tour today we do it all sunak
sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
the she I'm so rich frankly uh I'm going
to take the side of boozed up Brits
against these pomp you mean you're not
going to support mayor Jose
L stop ping to the nimes to the n sers
and The National Society for the
preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like they highly
paid Consultants don't really know what
they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you and we're just asking patients to be
patient with us are we we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
and Facebook and X formly known as
Twitter where is our where is our
unbiased news going to come from Welcome
to the talk it's really great to be back
my Little Darlings kids think all they
have to do is stay at home be silly take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok then
yeah problem solve you go who's fit as a
butcher dog him all right but but he's
now
ha t i nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know now you're
probably going to boot me off the show
this Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for
living got former PMS all over the joint
saying things the last few days we have
indeed yeah great first show you having
fun oh a ton of fun King PE and King
Cube I think there's only room for one
king man you know what I'm saying just
cuz they're skin folk don't mean they're
kin folks when I say I am God you think